the power of the mind I call it
we are not bill - why should we have
100% brain when we only are able to
control 20% doesn't make that their
science is a MCOs most of the blood flow
is always on the surface because of our
thinking ways the neurological pathways
we have learned to develop yes so I've
now found a way to get into the deepest
of the brain and with that unlocking the
possible power of the mind to become
just happy strong and healthy not a
circus act
I'm not into look at me what I can do
with a bla bla no I just discover what
innately
we are capacitated with everybody and
there is the unconditional love or yes
the unconditional love composed by the
guarantee to activate anything that
makes you happy
strong and healthy happiness is hormones
or four hormones the strength is the
metabolic processes in the in the cell
and we have proven that that we are able
to create more mitochondria or I mean
more ATP that doesn't matter how works
strength is there is energy and we are
able to guarantee flow therein we showed
that and then the last one is the health
is the going into the deepest layers of
the immune system it's all there it was
always there and it is connected to the
brain and now we found the pathways and
and it's up for awakening and with that
comes the the beginnings of the power of
the mind for everybody and there is the
spiritual journey because it is without
thoughts its feelings it's deep it's
it's like drugs but then your own we got
this t-shirt I could get high on your
own supply yeah and it's kind of nice
but at first let us clean up a clean
the place and get into learning people
to control and our balance their
depression bipolar anxiety fear that it
is no longer needed because 20% will
become 100 percent control
in the brain so let's talk about what
that protocol is like how do we begin
this process of engaging the mind in a
new way
yes so there I I came up with these
things
because I didn't find it in no books so
I went into nature and in nature you
have no word it doesn't it's not written
when I'm in a white art but I feel
suddenly instead of thought of a
paranoid because an anxiety and fear
because there's a wider I mean in my
short and it's less than half the oxygen
present and nobody's around and I can't
see anything but white eyes and rocks
and there I am four hours well none
feeling that you are not in anxiety but
okay you have a feel confident nice and
surprisingly you're looking at yourself
right
it's okay this power is part of the
power of the mind well which is able
through intuition orientation deeper
than our normal senses the sixth sense
sixth sense not a sick sense the sixth I
gotcha
it's almost sick in their society
because there is no confidence
confidence is part of the sixth sense
it's a confidence comes when you have
control within your own brain past a
normal sense Oracle perception you got
images and feelings sick sounds is able
to go into the future because it has no
time-space perception it is different
but it's there and you learned when it's
simply there not because
your logic says so know that because it
is there and you trust it then you feel
confident and it makes the right
calculations and this is what happened
there I felt confident I began to walk
and my orientation GPS anything is great
working even in a whiteout three hours
later I arrived in an advanced base camp
and was received by Tibetan sand they
must have seen a crazy pilgrim white man
coming out of a whiteout but they gave
me tea and butter when so where where
and when was this 2007 on Everest oh
this is your Everest okay yes yes out of
the air I gotcha okay so yeah that's
when you you you made it all the way up
to the Death Zone with basically just in
shorts yes no shirt right and then you
had a foot injury or something like that
that prevented you yeah thing is I
learned to to get into different
consciousness altogether by going into
nature because it wasn't in the books
would I try to find I am I want to find
the soul I want to find enlightenment
and the world has proven to be a place
where it is not and where they ignore
the soul's presence it's all of our
profits and power and tension and stress
and dominating and exploiting and
polluting that that is what is going on
this big monster I think we are like
dragon slayers we go for the right tools
and then go ahead we go past our fear
and turn the wheel and make effective
tools and bring it out to the world that
there is light in the world that there
is a soul in the world and that we have
a capacity to get rid of this
manipulative control and to find
absolute a deeper sense of control over
ourselves because we own really
own brain we are the owners of our
happiness strength and health Dave
Asprey asked me in this podcast women
what is enlightenment and please tell it
in what somebody else to and say it in
one set I said just be happy strong and
healthy and the rest is [ __ ] the
soul it's time for the soul to be here
and guaranteed and as I say past any
politics and bollocks and power and this
and culture and tradition and religion
the mother and Baghdad is the same as in
New York they just want a guarantee for
their children
happiness strength and health and now
because nobody was listening everybody
indulging into a religion and
differences instead of the equal side of
our all we just want to love our kids
wasn't it so that's what we want and
that's what we need to stand up and say
go through science no speculation
anymore the time had a you had to
speculate and to show you differences
with all the respect it only kills it
gives a bad quality of life no and a
health a depression and people earning
irrational amounts of money and the
other one not I see people homeless here
and I think a man it's still our so
until it is not solved that the
unconditional love which everybody
should owe like there are and owning
their own mind we have to keep on rich
and a a and stand up because [ __ ] the
past
what I all did and made our genetical
way of thinking in the through
epigenetics becomes genetics and now we
are stuck in the marsh and we got a
solve it yes that's what we do we stand
up and we say no to war no to disease no
to depression we say yes to happiness
strength and out and we prove it through
son
and that's makes us man